[Music]
what's good oh talk to James what's up
James hey John how's it going man we're
partying dude what's up
man uh well I'm guess I'm just going to
roll uh right into the question um so my
wife and I are on the brink of a
divorce and so my question for you I
guess the best way I can put it is how
do I
navigate uh you know these emotions and
everything that's going on and really
try to find myself right now because you
know obviously my sense of self is kind
of all over the place at the moment yeah
what happened
man um I got to go back a little ways so
I've struggled with uh varying degrees
of anxiet iety my whole
life and um it's you know EB and flowed
ups and downs but right before we got
married I I really hit the lowest point
in my life with my anxiety and um I was
just in pure survival mode for like a
year or more maybe um and so I just
couldn't be the best partner in the
world and so um the you know kind of the
Romantic an intimate part of our
relationship really started to uh fade
away and ever since that point we've
just never had the tools or or
understanding of how to kind of bring
that back and really strengthen that
side of our
relationship uh we were always really
good support systems for each other and
really best friends and still went out
and made a ton of memories together but
that side of the relationship never
truly
recovered hold on why why did y'all
choose that somebody chose that or y'all
chose it
together uh
we're we're both really good at
avoiding the tough conversations the the
awkward conversations I know but hold on
a sex don't avoid that it's like one of
the best parts second yeah you're about
to lose
everything and so if you're like
somebody who wants to avoid conflict and
you see a child about to walk in front
of a
truck you're like ah I'm just not good
at at at at hard
conversations and then he gets hit by
the truck like your marriage is almost
over yeah why not have the
conversations well we've we've been
having the conversations uh
you know but
obviously uh a little late in the game I
don't believe in late in the game I
don't believe in late in the
game well so let me let me run through
what she is telling me then
um she you know over the past six months
to a year she started uh you know talk
about how she feels trapped and
claustrophobic both just in the
relationship in her life uh her job
where she lives I mean just kind of
everything about her life right now she
just kind of
feels uh claustrophobic I guess was the
word she used and um you know recently
she's been talking about you know she
doesn't know she wants to be here
anymore um and she just doesn't have
hope that the relationship can be
changed and the real I guess final
kicker was she told me that she doesn't
even know if she wants to try to
uh heal the relationship I guess she's
been married to a a a light
socket yeah
so I what you just the way you just laid
that out what she said tells me that's
the sound of somebody who's exhausted
they're out because they're trapped in
an umbrella or like in a dome of well
it's just the anxiety it's just the
anxiety it's just the
anxiety yeah even your language is super
defeatist but listen dude like this
thing this anxi it's not something you
have it's not something that like
descends upon you like Co
did
right right it's a whole bunch of little
bitty choices that you make over a
period of
time and so my question she's not on the
phone so I can't talk to her but I'll
ask you why have you allow like what is
it about this that that is an identity
for you that's so powerful that you're
willing to lose your marriage over it
you're willing to have a sexless
marriage you're willing to have a
marriage you don't have conversations
with your best friend in the
world yeah I mean so I've been I've been
working really hard on myself within
like the last year um I'd found a
therapist that I love uh and I've been
working really hard but it's
just I I have I have reached out and
tried to what does what does working
really hard mean because I don't believe
you I say that because I love you but I
don't believe you like what does working
really hard
mean uh well like I said you know going
to therapy and having a lot of tough
conversations with my therapist here's
what it sounds like here's what it
sounds like it sounds like you have a
lot of
conversations and you have a lot more
conversations after that and then you
think a whole whole bunch and then you
read a book and listen to some podcast
then you have some more conversations
and your wife like can we just have
sex is that
fair yeah I mean but it's also a
reciprocation thing because I I I feel
like I have come to the table um you
know let's try this let's go to this
let's do this and it it just seems like
we just sit and spin our tires rather
than actually move forward with the
process of of doing said things and and
actually working
towards the healing part of it if that
makes
sense yes
and okay can I just can I be like super
honest with you because I love you
absolutely man all right so the father
of existential psychology the great irin
yolum
um he he kind of took up this this um
this mantle if you will this baton of
teaching future
therapist and he said as a one of the
greatest um tools a therapist has in
their toolkit is everything is
data and he said so what that means is
as a counselor if one of your clients
comes in and every time they come in
you're just so distract you can't pay
attention you like find yourself nodding
off you find yourself like keep having
inside your mind like I got to come back
got to come back that in it of itself is
data and a true loving counselor ask the
person do other people think you're
boring do other people say that you're
hard to be around because I'm struggling
and maybe that's where the work is okay
so I tell you all that to tell
you I'm struggling to connect with you
because every time I'm trying to connect
you Loop it around and have like well
and actually what we talked about is and
I could get this picture tell me I'm
crazy that you are like okay our
intimacy is off it's not good I'm
struggling with anxiety I've had lots of
Hard conversations
honey we're going to do a sex
thing and it's going to be a this and
it's going to be a that and then we're
and so really your wife instead of
entering into this her coming home and
the whole house has roses everywhere and
there's candles I don't know what she's
into and Tor Amos is playing and I or
Olivia Rodriguez is like I don't know
what she's into but whatever her thing
is instead of of that she gets off of
work and feels like she's going to an
exam like a final exam a test that she
needs to pass so her husband who's
anxious out of his
mind can be a little bit more of the
husband she signed up
for do you see the difference one of
these is a project and one of these is
part of my homework assignment between
me and my counselors I'm going to go
home I'm going to go for it I'm going to
be recklessly vulnerable with my
wife and I'm going to feel the attenion
in my body but I'm not going to put that
on her that's she's not have to her job
isn't to perform for me and make sure
she does everything right so that we can
be intimate whatever intimacy looks like
it could be doing it but it could be any
any a whole bunch of other stuff too do
you see what I'm saying yeah absolutely
absolutely am I right or wrong tell me
if I'm wrong man call me out if I'm if
I'm
off no you're you're definitely you're
definitely right it's
just I guess I don't know how to
necessarily get to that point you know
what I
mean you have to decide to so recklessly
run into this fire and through the
smoke and you're not your wife is
standing there in that fire getting
burned and you're like all right so what
we're going to do today is we are going
to examine the smoke and she's like will
you just come here with
me and it and and I'll be super honest
with you man I'm all about reality it
may be too late she may have checked out
and that's okay I mean it's not it's not
it's not okay like in the it's going to
hurt and be awful back to your original
question like how do you find yourself
we can talk through that real quick but
I don't think that's the thing right
now I think your wife is probably felt
like she's responsible for making sure
you're okay for so long and you have
been really working hard intellectually
through these
things and there's got to be a place
place where there's connection and
you're trying to connect intellectually
and you're trying to connect
project-based learning and she just
wants
you yeah see and and I hope you get what
I'm saying I I I do I do it's the
difference between like I am going to
rip your top two buttons off of your
shirt in a passionate kiss or
when I get home I will unbutton the top
button followed by the next top button
right the same things happening but one
of those is like this moment of Reckless
abandon and she might say hey stop and
that's going to be scary for you that's
vulnerability or she may rip your shirt
back but it's different than this
clinical step-by-step process where she
feels like she's being tested yeah
because none of us like to be in in math
class for the rest of our lives with the
one person we're supposed to be able to
drop our shoulders
with is she seeing somebody
else I I I firmly believe no I mean I
we've I've asked her that we you know I
I I honestly do not believe that to be
true no okay she's got to be getting
connections somewhere and maybe that's a
friend maybe that's a Fantasy Life maybe
that she's just shut the whole machine
off for now and she's tired of like
that's what that trapped feeling might
be that she's tired of having the whole
machine
off yeah I I think it's I think it's uh
not necessarily in love with someone
else but in love with something else I
think she's in love with the idea of not
being uh slowly being encased in
concrete yeah right like this this
impending sense like I got get I gotta
get out of here whatever here is here
may be you but it may be the whole
feeling of that whole situation so do
you think there's chance to save your
marriage or are you guys pass that has
she filed on
you no that there hasn't been any filing
uh we we don't have any kids or anything
so
it's it's there's not a lot to it in
those terms um hold on homie there's a
lot to
it it might not be as complicated but it
will still be as
violent right right I I think we're both
kind of just just in this limbo of of
what what do we do what are the next
steps either way we you know so if one
of you files on each other the moment
somebody files the relationship is over
and it is now a business
transaction and this is uncomfortable to
say but you don't business transaction
season is not the time to quote unquote
work on
yourself you're in the middle of a
business deal and we're going to get
through that
deal right and then we're going to let
the smoke dust clear and we're going to
try to make good choices during the
smoke and dust and when I say make good
choices we're not going to do anything
we can't take back we're not going to go
get somebody pregnant we're not going to
just immediately start dating all over
the place we're not going to um eat with
Reckless abandon we're still going to go
exercise we're still going to try to
sleep best we can even though we're
grieving like crazy you will have some
Netflix nights you'll have some of that
kind of stuff but we're going to do the
best we can to stay whole we're going to
have a group of guys that we hang out
with that we do life with we're going to
be whole through the this business
transaction and then we're going to
start asking what now where do we go
most people make a mistake when somebody
files they instantly like want to go
David goggin's the whole thing and you
can't because your body's in fight ORF
flight and grief at the same time it's
not a time to start a new program of
some sort you got to get through this
thing right it's like being in the
middle of a
marathon and all of a sudden you have
you're like I'm going to start a squat
routine like like dude finish the race
first got to finish the race and get
rest and then you can start talking
about squats right so finding yourself
that's this isn't the time if if yall
getting divorced there's a business
transaction right I also think there's a
place to sit down and
say I'm not out if you are I don't
believe in two sentences I don't believe
in too soon I just I don't know I just
think things are funny even if it's
awful like I don't believe in too soon
and I don't believe in too late it's too
late I don't believe that
and so to sit down and
say I realize that me getting well or
trying to get
well has put you in a microscope for the
last however many years and that's
exhausting I'm
sorry and you brother have to stop
wearing anxiety as an identity badge as
a way you walk around the world this is
this is my this is the way I do
it
and you have to take those intellectual
conversations that you have and those
lessons that you think about and think
about those hard conversations and you
have to start doing things
differently and that means you're going
to have to start getting
tougher and I don't mean that like I
don't feel my anxiety I mean tougher
like I'm going to do things when I don't
feel like it I'm going to exercise when
I don't feel like it I'm going to go to
work and be on time when I don't feel
like it I'm going to ask my wife every
single day of my life how can I love you
today I am going to put on my
calendar make a move
tonight put on her music create a world
take care of the dishes take care of the
things that that that all the the whole
environment that take your foot all the
gas pedals down and all the brakes off
in the house whatever that looks
like and I'm going to be vulnerably
recklessly vulnerable with my
wife not problem-based learning and her
being have taking the SAT every Saturday
night when yall want to hook up but
man all
in and that's probably to be some some
skills that you got to learn how to do
and it's going to be really vulnerable
and scary you're worth that by the way
and what a fun way to live
man that's you running through the fire
and letting your body know I get I'm I'm
getting your signals but she's safe
she's amazing and by the way you may do
all of this and she may still
leave and if she does you're gonna have
to grieve it
hard but why leave it on the
table don't leave a conversation unad
don't leave an experienced
untried go get your
wife go get your
wife